ciao a tutti ragazzi prima di criticare
quello che sto per dire arrivato a fini
di questo video perché ho troppe persone
ho visto che mi hanno criticato senza
manco aver visto il video in questione
scusate se solo un pochino infervorato
ma veramente ci sono stato così male che
finalmente adesso sto trovando le parole
soprattutto sono riusciti a chiudere un
cerchio che mi sta permettendo
finalmente di fare questo video perché
altrimenti prima sarebbe stato stupido
sarebbe stato basato sul nulla
io cura una rubrica questo youtube che
si chiama vita buttata esce ogni giovedì
all'interno di questa rubrica della
scorsa rubrica ho ricevuto il messaggio
di una ragazza un ragazzo che parlava di
un ragazzo per cui si stava frequentando
un certo punto ha cercato di diciamo
mentre lei dormiva entrare diciamo dalla
porta di servizio
ok lei non voleva e poi l'ha lasciato
fare
ma poi hanno finito diciamo facendolo
entrare dalla porta principale
ora io e l'ospite inizialmente abbiamo
riso perché il modo in cui lo ne parlava
era molto leggera abbiamo avuto un
momento in cui abbia detto però questo
atteggiamento non è corretto nei
confronti della ragazza insomma ci siamo
trovati per un momento in una zona
grigia
perché dare la tua testimonianza di una
roba di violenza in una rubrica leggera
e anche da come ne parlava alla ragazza
abbiamo optato per cercare un pochino di
alleggerire il tema senza però toglierlo
del tutto sotto mi è stato detto questo
lo stupro non si re non si ride il fatto
che la ragazza non si sia resa conto per
uno stupro non vuol dire che non sono
stupro e del piano questo tipo di
critiche mi ha messo in discussione ha
fatto dire cacchio non è che ho trattato
con leggerezza qualcosa di grave e non
me ne sono reso conto e quindi che cosa
ho fatto
ho subito tolto il video e ho rimontato
il video perché avevo anche una seconda
parte in modo da avere un contenuto
divertente ma soprattutto un contenuto
che non mandasse il messaggio sbagliato
ora sotto a questo video l'ultimo video
ho ricevuto commenti di persone ricevono
tu non puoi pensare che cancellando così
un messaggio automaticamente ti lavi la
coscienza assolutamente no assolutamente
no ma questo commento è un commento
cretino scusatemi ragazze se lo dico è
un commento stupido perché io nel
momento in cui metto in discussione
mi rendo conto dei commenti che
effettivamente sta passando un messaggio
sbagliato e la maggior parte dei
commenti sono ma fatevi una vita ma dai
ma che dite ma fregatevene quindi io
comunque la maggioranza dalla mia parte
che mi dice no
di base io ho ricevuto un sacco di
commenti di base che erano meglio per
quella minoranza di commenti che
dicevano no questa è una cosa seria
io ho deciso di togliere il video perché
perché non volevo che altri commenti di
persone che affrontavano magari quel
video con la stessa leggerezza
pensassero che fosse una cosa normale e
per quello che ho tratto un video perché
non tutti avrebbero reagito pensando a
questa è una cosa sbagliata
molte persona perbene detto crediamoci
anche noi sopra e io ho preferito prima
ancora di sincerarmi di qualsiasi cosa
di toglierlo perché mi metto in
discussione e io vi giuro in video le
persone in v.le invidio queste persone
che smettono di seguirmi oh oh oh oh mi
mettono degli insulti sotto il canale
perché perché ho sbagliato e non si può
sempre chiedere scusa quando si sbaglia
non che cosa fate quando fa ma
soprattutto le persone che non sbagliano
mai che conoscete voi in che modo vi
nascondono le loro per chi perfette non
esistono e mi sembra assurdo che debba
venire a dire io fatto sta non ci ho
dormito veramente perché comunque il
sotto sotto che continua a pensare non
tanto a me i ragazzi perché a me non me
ne frega niente se io faccio è giusto
che paghi e unico pensiero era ma questa
ragazza come sta
ma questa ragazza che cosa è successo
aveva fatto prima verso questo questo
video
ma io ho mandato un messaggio questa
ragazza ho aspettato quindi rispondesse
per capire che cosa stava succedendo
ho sbagliato io ho trattato con
leggerezza questo argomento oppure
questo argomento è veramente grave e non
era assolutamente leggero finalmente mi
ha risposto ho parlato con lei
e adesso l'ho chiesto pure permesso di
poter leggere diciamo la nostra
conversazione dopo fa temine vostre
opinioni ragazzi perché sono sacrosante
purtroppo accendono videocamere parlo
penso sempre in maniera in maniera
stupida che passi il cuore della gente
un po come quando un figlio ti dice ti
odio e tu capisci che non chi lo dirà
mai o quando tu dici mamma non voglio
più sentire il team e l'altra può
sentire due minuti dopo però va beh
scusate sto diventando ciao hicks non so
se è visto ma nel mio ultimo video
ricevuto svariate critiche legate alle
alle reazioni che ho avuto nei confronti
del tuo messaggio
vorrei innanzitutto chiederti scusa se
ti offesa con le mie parole in secondo
vorrei capire se vuoi che cosa sia
successo effettivamente attenendomi
anche alle riflessioni che sono state
fatte sulla tua esperienza
vorrei capire quanto questo evento sia
effettivamente uno stupro e soprattutto
capire il motivo che ti ha spinto a
di una cosa così importante e grave
commetto e tosto per con la polizia per
esempio te lo chiedo perché non sta
flagellando oltremodo per il modo in cui
ho gestito questa confessione e vorrei
cercare in te un pò di chiarezza se è
possibile
ti mando un bacio grandissimo goccia non
ho fatto neanche in tempo a vedere il
video in questione a dire il vero adesso
guardo le rispondo in realtà il video
non è presente è stato tolto per evitare
di dargli il messaggio sbagliato sotto
consiglio di alcuni utenti
quello che vedi è un ri edit del video
perché voleva evitare che la maggior
parte delle persone che non vedeva un
problema in un audio simile potesse
pensare che questa roba fosse normale
tranquilla ma di base i discorsi delle
persone mi hanno fatto pensare più che
altro a te e mi hanno spinto a voler
indagare sulla faccenda
dall'audio non sono riuscito a capire
effettivamente quanto grave fosse stato
il gesto è quanto forte il tuo esserti è
ribellata
in che rapporti foste né quanto sia
durata la storia tra voi avevo bisogno
di capire come mai non è fatto nulla é
lasciato correre
insomma sento la responsabilità di ciò
che mi ha detto risponde lei
mi dispiace che il mio audio ti abbia
che abbia aggravato di una simile
preoccupazione che ne ho parlato perché
io su questa storia sono totalmente
tranquilla perché nel momento in cui è
successa la cosa questa persona non mi
ha maltrattato ho fatto del male a parte
quello che ti ho detto ma sono stato
stupido di a lasciarlo fare perché
volevo vedere fino a che punto sarebbe
arrivato io ne parlo tranquillamente
come se fosse un aneddoto divertente e
mi spiace che tu abbia potuto modificare
il video avrei voluto potermi spiegare
anche con le persone che ti hanno
accusato di essere stato leggero sulla
questione mi dispiace non aver visto il
video però cavolo
tu sei sicura le chiedo io che non sia
stato uno stupro perché alcune persone
hanno percepito il fatto che tu ti
lamentavi e gli avessi detto di smettere
ma che lui continuasse a farlo con la
tua contro la tua volontà
io ammetto di aver la percepita in
maniera più leggera ma avuto paura ma di
essere stato io leggero davanti a una
situazione grave invece non ti
preoccupare minimamente dell'accusa la
mia persona adesso mi interessi sono tu
lei no tu hai capito benissimo lui era
intorni veglia e non si è neanche reso
conto di quello che ha fatto da quello
che mi ha detto poi dopo io mi sono
lamentata ma aver potuto interromperlo
quando volevo solo che non ho fatto
perché volevo capire che persona fosse
comunque ti ringrazio davvero molto per
interesse lo apprezzo e spero di averti
tranquillizzato le risponde le tue
parole sono un vero sollievo
ho dormito calcola per paura che lo
stessi bene molto brevemente fare un
video vabbè non dirò il tuo nome ma
posso anche rassicurare le persone
perché un sacco di persone si sono
preoccupate comunque tutto questo avete
fatto bene avete fatto bene perché
appena ma ed è svegliato e mi sono
preoccupato lei dice sì certo deve
assolutamente farlo e mi spiace che
forse non sono state più leggera nel
raccontarlo di modo che tutti potessero
solo farsi una grassa risata
l'ha detto io in realtà avevo capito non
magari non è stato chiaro per tutti ti
mando un un enorme bacio grazie di cuore
non sai come sono più sollevato grazie
ancora conferme ci siamo detti un
pochino di cose affettuose adesso questo
è il dato di fatto ma alla luce di
questa cosa vorrei aggiungere una
piccola piccola piccola postilla perché
perché la maggior parte delle persone
che seguono il mio canale sono donne e
ed e a voi che voglio parlare perché io
credo che queste qui debbano essere
occasioni di crescita e non ho solamente
occasioni per sentirsi un pochino
collego ferito e non essere stati capiti
perché molto probabilmente ho sbagliato
anch'io se uno non ha capito
effettivamente o magari sbagliato
anch'io ammontare questo questo audio
che per me era così lampante mentre
invece un sotto sotto lampante non lo
era affatto sono contento che a questa
ragazza non sia successo niente ma allo
stesso tempo io invito a tutte le
persone che parlano di queste cose qui
molestie maniaci persone che allungano
le mani di non parlarne con leggerezza
non è una chiacchiera da fare con
l'amica perché il maniaco del bla
autobus a volte allunga la mano se voi
avete una persona che anziché si azzarda
uomo donna che voi siate uomo donna che
questo sia se si azzarda a toccarvi
contro la vostra volontà voi alzato il
telefono e chiamate subito la polizia
voi denunciate queste persone non si sa
mai
argomento di risata con gli amici non si
sa mai argomento di chiacchiera così
leggera per dare la mente
perché siamo troppo fighi e nessuno
riesce a starci a starci lontano auto
sfigata perché nessuno ti desidera no
ragazzi questa è roba seria
ci si va in carcere ed è giusto che ci
si vada la violenza non è mai la
risposta io non credo nell'uguaglianza
non siamo nati tutti quanti uguali io
sono uomo tu sei donna tousen ero io
sono bianco
tu sei statuario io lotto per esserlo ma
di base
il discorso è che io credo nella parità
credo che ogni cosa che noi abbiamo non
ci renda superiore agli altri
siamo diversi sì ma siamo pari e questo
è un pensiero che bisogna infilarsi
nella testa adesso io vi ho detto come
la penso
scusate per il respiro perché vi giuro
molto per ventola
chiuderò la cosa e scoppia in un pianto
disperato perché me ne sono veramente
vissuta male
l'unica cosa che però dico è porca
miseria ragazzi se io sono in
transfobico maschilista a amico degli
stupratori veramente voi non avete visto
che c'è là fuori possa essere un cattivo
esempio per un sacco di cose ma
ragazzino quando si tratta di donne
veramente un iter è così quando si
tratta di violenza ma io che sono stato
il primo a subirla persone che è
conosciuto sono stati i primi i primi
che in parte è anche in aspetti piccoli
più grandi la vita hanno subito queste
cose
ragazzi non si può parlare così non si
possono dire certe cose perché se questo
qui è promuovere gli stupri è veramente
non so più comunque bilancino pesiamo le
parole ed è veramente difficile parlare
io chiudo questo video non ho potere
sulle vostre vite ma voi ce l'avete
state la scelta giusta
io non posso farlo per voi